[Music]
slenderman the movie sees released this
month and as always the man-made monster
of mystery has a lot of hype surrounding
it
created in 2009 the Slender Man has
gained a huge internet reputation over
the last decade and has went on to star
on games documentaries and more
throughout this video I will be
discussing the myth of the Slender Man
in fiction as well as the real-life
murder trial that was attributed to the
character there will be some content
here that young viewers may find
disturbing so please be advised with
that out the way I'm definition and this
is my Slenderman explained video the
Slender Man originated as a creepypasta
internet meme in 2009 created by
something awful for amusement to search
the Slenderman is depicted as a black
suit wearing thin and unnaturally tall
humanoid with a completely blank head
and face often located in forests the
Slenderman is known for stalking
traumatizing and abducting people mainly
children Serge created the character
when he contributed to black and white
images to the forum that were made up of
groups of children and the digitally
added Slender Man composited of them
Serge supplemented his submission with
snatches of text supposedly from
witnesses describing the abductions of
the group of children and giving the
character the name the Slender Man the
quote under the first photograph read we
didn't want to go we didn't want to kill
them but it's persistent silence and
outstretched arms horrified and
comforted us and at the same time
the quote underneath the second
photograph read one of the two recovered
photographs from the Sterling City
Library blaze notable for being taken
the day which 14 children vanished and
for what is referred to as the
Slenderman deformities cited his film
defects by the officials buyer at
library occurred one week later actual
photograph confiscated as evidence
surged attributed the characters
creation to inspiration from HP
Lovecraft Stephen King the tall man from
the film phantasm and more surges
intention was to formulate something
whose motivations can barely be
comprehended and which caused an ease in
terror in general populations the
Slender Man quickly became an internet
phenomenon and went viral this rise in
popularity spawned numerous works of
fanfiction cosplays online art and more
however the character got his first real
big break in 2013 with the arrival of
the game slender the eight pages slender
the eight pages is set in a dense forest
during the middle of the night the
players objective is to collect all 8
pages located in various areas of the
forest while avoiding the Slenderman as
the player collects pages the fog in the
forest grows thicker and Slenderman
appears closer to the players location
though the characters sprinting speed
slowly increases as well Slenderman
moves by teleporting creeping around the
player but only from certain distances
if he gaze at the character too long
static begins to fill the screen and
death eventually follows the game was
given a full fledge release in 2015 with
Slenderman the arrival and it follows
much of the same pattern as the
aforementioned title but with improved
graphics expanded areas and a wider
character roster Slenderman
arrival received mixed reviews with many
citing its scares atmosphere and sound
design is being standout in the genre
whilst the character is mainly made up
from media there is also a far more
controversial thing as
from its creation on May 31st 2014 in
Wisconsin to twelve-year-old girls
lured their friend into the woods and
stabbed her 19 times in an attempt to
impress what they believed to be the
Slenderman the victim crawled to the
road where she was found
and after six days in hospital that made
a full recovery
there was a long and lengthy trial for
the two attackers but they were
eventually found not guilty because of
reasons of insanity by February 2018
they were both convicted and sentenced
to long periods in mental health
institutions during the trial they both
stated that they believed the Slender
Man to be real and carried out the
stabbing to prove their loyalty to him
desperately hoping to become his proxies
they sought to show the world his
existence and to prevent him from
harming their families while staking
them under his wing they believed that
the only way to do this would be to kill
someone after which they would become
servants of the Slenderman and live in
his mansion in nicoleff National Forest
in the aftermath of the stabbing the
creepypasta wiki was blocked throughout
the school district however a statement
from the creator of the Slender Man was
posted to the creepypasta wiki
expressing condolences for all those
involved the site later held a
fundraiser for the victim in order to
showcase that the visitors to
creepypasta were not bad people just
because they like scary stories the
incident has went on to spark debates on
child internet access that rages on
still to this day and whilst we may
never have an answer as to what the
correct direction to take is it's clear
that the Slender Man has moved far
beyond his original meme origins as
always I'd love to hear your thoughts on
Slender Man are you going to see the
film and what do you think will happen
in it comment below and let me know and
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and subscribe to my channel I
create content like this weekly and
they'll definitely be something on here
that you love if you're a fan of film
make sure you keep an eye out for my
Slender Man the movie ending explain
video which is due to drop next week and
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best I'll see you next time
peace
[Music]
[Music]